so thanks for coming yeah I was asked to
fill in for EM pacer who's down in
Berkeley and couldn't make it today I
was just down there last week talking
with him and Fernando Perez about
Jupiter no books and some of the things
that we've been trying to do with them
in connection with this project writing
a book and they thought that it might be
interesting for people to hear something
about what we've been doing so I'll tell
you a little bit about sort of the
background of this particular book and
what we're trying to do and give a demo
of some of the things that we've been
figuring out ways that we think are
reasonable to do it but they're probably
better ways to do some of these things
I'm also very much looking for feedback
from other people or ideas about better
ways to do some of these things so I'm
up here at the University of Washington
in the applied mathematics department
also a senior data science fellow in the
Science Institute although my background
is mostly in computational science
rather than data science a numerical
solution of differential equations in
particular and so the book that that
I'll be talking about is one that we're
writing on what's called riemann problem
in hyperbolic partial differential
equations which may not mean much to you
so I'll try to give you a little
background about what that means first
so that you have some appreciation for
what we're trying to do in the in the
notebooks that go along with this book
and if you're interested in playing
around with any of these it's all on get
up so what is the remand problem well
basically the sort of differential
equations we study model wave
propagation of pretty much anytime can
be modeled with hyperbolic partial
differential equations and the riemann
problem is what we call the sort of
simplest example where you take the
equation you're interested in and in one
space dimension plus time time-dependent
wave propagation and you take that
initial or take initial conditions for
that partial differential equation to be
simply a piecewise constant function
with a single discontinuity and then as
it evolves in time you get waves that
spread out from that initial
discontinuity and that seems like a very
simplified situation and it is but it
turns out understanding what happens in
that simple case is kind of the
t-piece of analyzing differential
equations particularly nonlinear
differential equations where the
solution structure can be difficult to
figure out even in that simplest case
and it's also kind of building block for
a large class of numerical methods that
can be then used to solve the same
equation with much more interesting
initial conditions or for real
applications so for the last twenty five
years or so I've been involved in a big
open source software project called claw
PAC which stands for conservation laws
package these hyperbolic PDEs are often
called conservation laws because they
model things like conservation of mass
momentum and energy that's how you drive
the equations often and so there as I
said wave propagation problems of all
sorts can be solved with the same sort
of software and being able to solve the
riemann problem for a particular
application is basically the building
block that the user would plug into our
software to specify some new equation
that they want the sauce that has this
this hyperbolic type so it's been used
to solve problems in acoustics in in
earthquake seismic waves shock waves
that arise in compressible gas dynamics
airflow around the aircraft or or
astrophysics problems traffic jams on a
highway you can model with hyperbolic
equations tsunamis various other kinds
of waves in particular tsunamis is a one
of the main research areas i've been
looking at for the last 10 years or so
and we have a variance of the clawback
software called gio claw that we use
extensively for that application and so
I'll use the shallow water equations
that are used in tsunami modeling as one
example in illustrating these notebooks
so here's one example of a tsunami
simulation just to show you sort of real
problem that we're interested in looking
at this was the big tsunami that was
generated by the earthquake off the
coast of Japan in 2011 about three hours
after the earthquake the red here is a
elevation above sea level the dark blue
is below sea level as this wave is
propagating across the ocean and so we
have codes that can model this wave
propagating using adaptive mesh
refinement so we use much finer grids in
some regions where the action is
and much coarser grids other places and
so on I won't get into any of the
details of that but if we zoom in on
what the solution looks like for example
30 minutes after the earthquake near the
coast of Japan and then zoom in on this
black square what you see is what we're
really doing in these numerical methods
is discretizing the domain as a series
of rectangles and within each rectangle
we're assuming the depth of the water is
constant or constant across the
rectangle and so we just have a sort of
piecewise constant solution on each time
and then the numerical methods that
solve the PDS are based on taking the
interfaces between the grid cells where
you have a jump from one value to
another and solving one of these riemann
problems which gives you waves
propagating away from the interface and
into the neighboring cells and using
those waves to update the solution over
some very small time step and then
repeating that many times over and
there's lots of other bells and whistles
that are put in to make it an effective
numerical method but the basic idea and
the reason that this riemann problem is
important is because we view the
solution as being piecewise constant at
any given time and so the way to evolve
the solution is to understand what
happens at the interface between two
constant states so here's a very
simplified version of that where we have
initial condition consisting of two
different levels of water and here I
colored the water is red and blue and
put some stripes in so you can think of
that as just being a dye that's being
carried along with the color it's not
affecting the solution what's important
here is the the height of the the
solution and this is what's called a dam
break problem where we start with
initially zero velocity in both sides of
this interface but we have a jump in the
height so it's like a dam is holding
back the red water the blue water is the
lower level to the right so this is a
simple example of a riemann problem for
whether called the shallow water
equations which just model the depth of
the water and the velocity in the one
dimensional situation assuming that
there's no variation in velocity in the
vertical direction it's all just a
horizontal velocity
and the equations we're actually solving
in this case are written down here these
one-dimensional shallow water equations
on a flat bottom the first equation is
the conservation of mass the second
equation is conservation of momentum
basically and they relate to the time
derivatives to the spatial derivatives
so what happens if we solve this remind
problem start with this initial data now
remove the dam so the water should start
flowing well what you expect of course
is that the deeper red water is going to
start flowing to the right but how is
that going to happen
what sort of waves do you get well it
turns out that what you get is something
that looks like this where you have a
compression wave a shock wave or a
hydraulic jump in the case of water it's
often called that's moving to the right
in this case into the shallower water
where there's a almost jump
discontinuity between shallow water and
somewhat deeper water that's moving at
some nonzero velocity and then to the
left you have a wave propagating that's
called a rarefaction wave or an
expansion fan where the water is
smoothly decreasing in depth and
increasing in velocity as the water is
accelerated so again going back to the
beginning we start with this initial
condition and you get basically two
waves one a discontinuity moving to the
right the other sort of spreading fan
moving to the left and so that would be
the solution of this Ramon problem for
this particular case of the shallow
water equations okay so I've shown you
one particular solution of a Ramon
problem for this set of equations but
you might be wondering well what happens
if I change the data here and it's a
little hard with this I could have made
up some more slides that show other
things but it's even harder if you're
reading about this in a book and trying
to understand what goes on you might
like to be able to play around with the
conditions here so another thing I do in
addition to developing software and
working on these applications is I like
to write books or at least I've written
several over the last 30 years or so
they've been at UW as I sort of
developed course notes on various
aspects of these problems so I've
written several sort of old-fashioned
classical books on the topic of
hyperbolic problems and wave propagation
problems
there's lots of other books out there
they've been written by very good people
so good question is why are we writing
another book well the answer is that I
think the do clear note books have
really opened up completely new ways of
presenting this material and interacting
with it in ways that I think is very
valuable to students and researchers who
are trying to learn about all this so
there's lots of other books that have
been written by now using ghupat or
notebooks and we've looked at the number
of those and I encourage you if you
haven't looked at this gallery of
interesting Jupiter notebooks online you
can find lots of examples of various
notebooks but we've faced a few
challenges in dealing with the types of
problems that we're looking at in
particularly looking at sort of these
time-dependent solutions where we want
to see how things evolve in time that
we've been trying to address with some
of the work that that we're doing now so
what would we like out of these
notebooks well what we're trying to
develop is a collection of notebooks
that can be viewed as chapters in a book
that had cross referencing between the
chapters equation numbers that you can
refer back to bibliographic citations
all the things you would expect in a
book that also work well in the
notebooks and of course the notebooks
should be interactive so that people can
play around with things you'd like to
see this time evolution you'd like to be
able to play an animation or have a
slider bar to see how the ramond
solution evolves with time but you'd
also like to be able to change the
states to the left and the right and see
how that changes the solution or for
some systems and equations are various
physical parameters you'd like to play
around with and see how that changes the
solution so you want to be able to play
around with them but not everyone will
be running the notebooks or willing to
download and install them or even run
them in the cloud maybe so we'd also
like to produce from these notebooks a
set of HTML pages that are easier for
people to browse through without having
to actually run anything that maybe
won't have all the interactivity that
the notebook does but at least still has
some animations or things like that in
it and we also like to turn this into an
actual physical book we're hoping to
publish this in addition to having the
notebooks available online publishing it
as a book that might be useful to sit
down and read through and then go to the
note
when you want to play around with some
specific thing so we'd like to export
from the notebooks directly to a PDF
file that is reasonable as a printed
book and then also in addition to having
the notebooks available for people to
run on their own computer have them
hosted on the cloud so that people can
easily play around with them so those
are some of the things that we've been
sort of aiming for supporting so let me
switch to looking at a few of these
notebooks and then I'll talk at the end
abit about some of the tools we found
useful in doing this and--but as we go
along to see so if you go to that github
repository you can download these
notebooks if you want to play around
with them but there's one called index
which has sort of our working table of
contents anyway of the notebooks that we
have put together so far I should say
this is a joint project with two of my
former PhD students
David Ketchikan and Mauricio Durazo we
put a lot of work into this as well so
let me just show you a couple of
notebooks so first of all if we go to
the introduction here we describe what
this riemann problem is and we give some
examples including the sort of dam break
problem that i showed you on the slides
only here it's in a form where it's
using the interactive capabilities of
Jupiter so that you can use the time
slider here this particular version in
the notebook is really or in this
introduction is really designed to sort
of talk people through some of the basic
ideas so there's some other
corresponding figures down here that are
set up with different initial conditions
for example if it's deeper on the right
then the left then what you get is sort
of the waves in the opposite
configuration with a shock wave moving
to left and expansion wave moving to the
right or if you have water that's
flowing towards the middle from both
sides so you start with constant depth
but a positive velocity on one side and
negative velocity on the other then you
get two shockwaves moving out instead or
if you have flow that
flowing outwards on both sides then you
get to rarefaction waves for example so
this introduction there's some sort of
specified problems here but of course
the user could go in and modify things
here if they wanted to see what would
happen if we change the initial
conditions maybe make the depth two on
the left but keep everything else the
same then you can see how that changes
the solution of course it's nicer if you
have actually a bigger menu of options
that people can change directly so from
here we can also go into there's another
notebook on the chawla water equations
it's quite a long notebook actually that
describes much more about the theory and
has a number of things but down to the
very bottom there's a similar animation
but where you can now change the left
and right state with slider bars as well
as having a slider bar for the time so
one thing that we wanted to do as I said
is to make it possible to have these
sorts of things in the notebook but then
also produce from these HTML pages so
that people can just browse through them
without actually running them and also
eventually a PDF version so let me just
show you sort of what we've done there
if we go back to the introduction back
at the top there's an import statements
and in particular we import from I PI
widgets we import interact we then have
a script that turns these into HTML
pages by using MB convert and in the
process of doing that we also before
running and B convert we replace any
line that says from I PI widgets import
interacts with a different line which
using at the HTML version of this it's
been replaced by our own version of
interact from utils j/s animate widgets
import interact and this instead of
using the interactive widgets which
require actually running the notebook
instead uses the j/s animation package
developed by Jake van der glass which
basically takes a set of images and
combines them using some Java so
ripped into an animation that can be
played in the web browser and this can
be played now on the HTML page without
having to be running the notebook so
that's the way that we've so far found
to handle sort of taking some of these
interactive things and turning them into
a static HTML page but that still has at
least some of the interactive features
and then as I mentioned we also want to
turn it into a PDF file for a book and
so again you can use nd convert combined
with there's a package called book book
which helps to take a whole collection
of notebooks and turn them into chapters
in the book and so from all of the
notebooks we get a PDF file that has all
of the chapters and now if we go to that
same introduction what we see here make
this bigger is that in our conversion
the PDF we replace that interacts with a
yet another version of that function
from this snapshot would schatz widgets
module that we wrote we import interact
which basically takes the the widgets
that were defined and this interacts and
produces a static figure at one
particular value of the time so in the
widget in the interactive notebook we
specified an initial value of zero
because in the interactive notebook it
makes sense to start at time zero and
then as you slide the slider bar you see
time evolving for the for the PDF file
it wouldn't really make sense to only
show the initial conditions you wouldn't
see the structure of the solution so we
also have in our post-processing script
code that takes a value of zero any
place in these interacts and replaces it
with some slightly later time point two
or something that we've specified so
that we get a more interesting picture
so that's one thing that we've sort of
struggled with is how do we convert the
interacts directly to something that
worked looks nice in the PDF file or in
the HTML file now when I was at Berkeley
last week I was talking with Fernando
and M about maybe trying to automate
this more and building into the interact
within the notebook
additional parameters that would specify
what value you want to use when you're
converting to HTML and maybe a different
value that you want to use when
converting to PDF so that you could more
automatically handle these various
things okay so let's see another thing
we go back to this set of slider bars
you know we can move the left and right
state around here but it would be even
nicer if we could pick up the states and
sort of drag them around somehow and
we're not doing that directly in the
notebooks yet but we hope to kind of
incorporate this in we do have a sort of
a more Java pure JavaScript version
using MPL d3 of the mauricio wrote which
allows you to drag the states around so
what's shown in the upper left corner
here is what's called a phase plane
where the depth H is on the horizontal
axis and the momentum hu is on the
vertical axis so each of our states
correspond to a particular depth
momentum combination and so this sort of
riemann problem that we were looking at
that has this left going rarefaction
wave and right going shock corresponds
for example to a left state that had
positives are a larger depth than the
right state and both of them with zero
velocity
what's shown over here is the view of
this solution in the XT plane so
starting with this initial discontinuity
there's a shock wave propagating at
constant velocity and this expansion fan
spreads out in such a way that the
solution is constant on raise from the
origin and so this XT plane shows you
the speeds at which these waves are
propagating and and the way the solution
is evolving so here you can drag this up
and down to see the time evolution but
you can also over here in the phase
plane take one of these states and move
it around and then you can see that
depending on where this left state lies
relative to the right state you might
have two shockwaves you might have a
shock wave and a rarefaction wave you
might have two rarefaction wave
and so a lot of the theory of the
riemann problem is understanding how to
compute the solution these curves that
are drawn here in the phase plane are
fundamental to figuring out given a left
and right state how do you find the
intermediate state this middle state or
certain curves intersect in between and
how do you determine whether each of the
waves is a shock wave or rarefaction
light and so that the notebooks and
textbooks that already exist go into
great detail about how to go about doing
that but from just reading a book you
don't get a very good feel for what
happens as you vary those those states
and so I think these kinds of tools make
it much easier I hope for students to
understand really what's going on and
how how the structure of these
mathematical problems evolves as you
change the data so that's the goal and
at the moment this which you can
actually embed within a notebook by just
displaying it as HTML but then we
haven't figured out how to translate
that into the PDF version for example so
we're still working on that aspect of it
let's see I guess I'll show one other
sort of menu of options that is this
kind of thing is relatively easy to do
in the jupiter notebook to describe
here's again a phase plane this is for
compressible gas dynamics problem where
you actually have conservation of mass
momentum and energy but it's just
projected onto the pressure and velocity
plane here and there's various things
you can change again you could change
the left and right state in this case
again with slider bars but you can also
change the parameters that determine the
us the equation of state for this
particular gas that you're looking at
and as you change those parameters that
changes the way these curves behave in
phase space or you can choose various
different plot options for how you want
to display the results again when we
render this as a PDF currently or as an
HTML file currently all that shows up
when you then be convert is the plot it
doesn't show the menu or the particular
parameter settings that you put in
so this is another thing we were talking
about the Berkeley last week it would be
nice if there were a way to
automatically render the menu so it
would at least show you what parameter
settings were used in the figure that
you're seeing for example okay so those
are a few of the things that we're
trying to do here's some of the tools
that we found useful so far we've been
trying to describe some of the things we
do on the wiki page that goes along with
the github repository it's not all
completely described there but we'll be
adding more to it we're still very much
in the process of experimenting with
different things seeing what works well
and what doesn't I mention this book
book project that we're using to combine
all of the notebooks into a coherent
book where the reference from one
notebook to another notebook and the
notebooks gets turned into a reference
to another chapter in the book
automatically there's also an ND
extension for equation numbering that
lets you do equation numbering I guess I
was going to show you also if we go back
to the shallow water book for example
and go up to the top rather long
notebook but so here we have the shallow
water equations of course the nice thing
about the notebook is you can this is
all just marked down with latex
formatting and you can put in labels for
equations the same way you would in a
latex document and then when you execute
it actually gives you what looks like an
error message here that's just because
there was a numbered equation here and
if you start changing markdown cells and
have numbered equations you might be
adding or subtracting equations and so
that has to change the numbering of
every other equation in the document so
this is just to remind you to go up here
and click this button at the top which
renumber x' all of the equations in the
document if necessary so that's coherent
again so those kinds of things are
nicely built in and then you can refer
back to equations and as a course get
transferred over to both the HTML and
the PDF versions as as hyperlinks as
well
yeah and then the bibliography also
using Dib tech to HTML we can take
basically a bid text file and turned
into two HTML page that can be referred
to from the document we have a pointer
in here I guess there is a reference in
here but you can go directly to the
biography and unfit tech is also what's
used for the eh put the latex file to
make the PDF eventually and then another
tool that we found very useful if you
don't know about it is MV dime I guess
it's pronounced which is a notebook diff
and merge tool which makes it easier to
compare versions of the notebook on when
we're using git and since this whole
project is about the notebooks and we
have three co-authors changing things we
often have conflicts within the
notebooks and so it's much easier to
resolve those using this tool than
trying to work with the JSON file as
just the text file so those are some of
the tools we've been using and whoops
and the other thing we've been looking
at is how do we make the notebooks
themselves easier for people to use
without having to download and install
all of the various dependencies so we do
have a docker file in the in the
repository that people can use to build
a docker image we're planning to put on
docker hub eventually we've been using
learning to play around with windows
azure as a platform for presenting the
notebooks and then also binder which it
has is being redeveloped by the berkeley
group and the new version seems to work
quite nicely so you can paste into the
binder page any github repository and it
will build it on binder in this case it
was already built so when I click that
it just brought up a notebook server
make this bigger a notebook server for
this particular repository and within
here we have all of the notebooks which
can be executed
so I think those were the main things I
wanted to mention again if people have
ideas for other things other tools we
could be using or better ways to do some
of this I'd be more than happy to talk
with you about other or share more of
our experiences about the details of
some what we've done also
again everything is on in the github
repository including some documentation
at least of what we would do I'll stop
there but if there any questions happy
to questions well that's a big so
earlier today there's a presentation for
another plotting library called BQ plot
which works with I PI widgets oh okay
that might be something you could
consider incorporating yeah and I know I
guess a BQ plots I haven't looked at you
know okay also does some of the sorts of
things that we're trying to do and we
play the brown bit with that in the past
but we need to spend more time with
enols and thanks in the hills for
minuite millions well cool how about a
great round for Randi I get and
everybody have a great weekend